[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
SETH SHOSTAK: Hi, team.
Welcome to a live stream here
on Facebook Live from Google
in Mountain View, California--
lovely, glamorous Mountain
View, California in the
heart of the Silicon Valley,
or if not the heart, at least
somewhere behind the ribcage.
We're going to talk today
about something that you
probably don't think terribly
much about but should,
and that's the interaction
of the cloud and science.
This may be the
future of science.
If you're doing science,
this may be your future.
In any case, I have with me
an expert on the Google Cloud
and how it interacts
with science.
Let me just tell you a couple
of sentences about myself.
My name is Seth Shostak.
And I'm a Senior Astronomer
at the SETI Institute,
also here in Mountain
View, California.
And our job is to look for life
in space, and in particular,
whether there's any
intelligent life in space.
But we're going to talk about
that maybe a little bit later.
At the moment I
want to introduce
our expert, Massimo Mascaro.
And Massimo, tell us a
little bit about yourself.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Absolutely.
Nice to meet everyone.
Yeah, my name is
Massimo Mascaro.
I'm a Technical
Director here at Google.
And actually, I work
specifically on Applied AI.
I have a background in physics.
Actually, I was a space nerd
and an aspiring astrophysicist,
but then I got into
competition neuroscience.
I got [INAUDIBLE] by the
idea of neural networks
and I started working in AI,
and I've been doing that since.
Here at Google, I'm
in Google Cloud.
And what I do is that I work
with some of the largest Google
clients, helping them applying
AI inside their problems.
So this actually how I came
to work on this project,
because about in
April last year,
we started working with NASA,
in particular, the Frontier
Development Lab.
And at that point, actually,
my passion for space kicked in
and I decided to step
in and work with them.
SETH SHOSTAK: Now,
you talk about FDL.
That's the Frontier
Development Lab.
That's an initiative
of NASA, right?
MASSIMO MASCARO: It is.
SETH SHOSTAK: So how
does NASA interact
with the private sector,
because Google, after all, is
in the private sector?
MASSIMO MASCARO: It is.
So FDL is a really, really
cool program that NASA runs.
What they do is they
seek partnership
with basically private
companies to help out
on some of the biggest
challenges that NASA has.
One of the big themes that FDL
research about-- in fact, I
would say is one of the
most prominent ones--
is actually artificial
intelligence
applied to NASA's problem.
So Google--
SETH SHOSTAK: Can you give
me an example of a problem?
MASSIMO MASCARO:
For example, I mean,
one of the things
actually that we
work on this year is
actually a big problem
in artificial
intelligence, is how
do you actually
automatically detect
transiting of planets
from the signals
that you get from
your space telescopes.
It is a problem where if
you want machine learning
is very, very useful tool.
Because right now
actually a lot of this
is done manually, by
actual astronomers
and there is actually
high error rates in that.
SETH SHOSTAK: So
in the cloud you
have, of course, the
opportunity for sharing data.
Anybody can get
to it presumably,
if they're interested in
the problem of looking
for planets around other
stars, just to follow up
on your example.
They can get to the data.
But they can get to
something else there too.
They can get to tools, right?
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yes.
So there are, I think,
actually three main things
that you can get in the cloud.
So the first one, of
course, is the ability
to get a lot of data in and have
very, very fast access to it.
That's actually bread and butter
and you have to have that.
The other thing is computation.
So on the cloud you can
get a lot of computation
to run on top of that data.
And that actually is
also very important.
And this actually, by
the way, in science
it's not like a super
easy thing to do.
I mean, believe it or not.
I mean, some of the
largest supercomputers
today are used for science.
But actually, they're not
very available to a lot
of scientists.
And then the third
thing is in Cloud
we built a series of
higher level of things that
allow you to do things from
analytics and data processing
to AI and machine learning.
They actually are tools that
you build on top of these two
layers of data and computation.
They allow you to do those
kind of things actually
much more easily.
SETH SHOSTAK: Now,
suppose-- all right,
I'm a research scientist.
I kind of know what
they look like.
There are a lot of
them near my office.
They're sitting in their cubes.
They're sitting in their
offices-- whatever.
And they're on a desk
and in the corner
there's a stack of reprints that
only five people in the world
can actually understand.
And they're working
on a problem.
Maybe that problem
is exactly this one.
They want to know are there
a lot of planets out there?
Are there not a lot
of planets out there?
Now, in the past, they would
have to go get some data
themselves.
And they would have exclusive
use of that data at least
for a while, even if
it was from the Hubble
telescope or some
publicly owned instrument.
And now, they need to
go through those data
and take a look is there
something interesting in it.
They'd write some
code themselves.
It would be proprietary.
They would probably
spend half their lives
debugging their own code.
And they would have
a limited data set
and that's how they would work.
Now, how is that
going to happen now?
I mean, I'm sitting in
my office wondering,
hey, look, how am I going to
beat all those competitors out
there?
[LAUGHTER]
MASSIMO MASCARO: So I
mean, a couple of things.
I mean, of course,
scientific data
very often actually
come from sources
like what you mentioned.
So for example, I can tell you
that in the work that we've
been doing with
FDL on exoplanets,
we've been working with
Kepler's data that is
now actually a public data set.
But there is a delay because
there are certain research
institutions that usually have
exclusiveness on those data.
For example, we haven't worked
yet on the newly test data.
That is the new--
so for those who
don't know Kepler
is the old exoplanet
source satellite.
SETH SHOSTAK: Oldish.
Dead for what, a month?
[LAUGHS]
MASSIMO MASCARO: A month,
but has been actually
in space for 10 years or more.
And TESS is just newly launched.
I mean, they launched it
with SpaceX last April.
And TESS actually is in
orbit and is collecting data,
but that data is
not available yet.
It is available to NASA and
to some of these research
scientists, but
not to the public.
So two things actually there.
Of course, you have to
have access to the data.
But very, very large data
sets are now becoming public.
And in any case, it
is always possible
even if you have private
data sets to work with Google
and have it imported in a
private setup inside the cloud.
The cloud doesn't have
to be public in that it's
open to everyone, if
you don't want to.
We have a lot of like, if you
want, commercial customers, who
have very, very sensitive
data that do not share.
So that's possible.
But I would say that the
very exciting thing is
when you work on
these public data sets
and now actually you have
access to these data.
But very often having
access to the data--
I can download all the Kepler
data sets from NASA today,
if I want to.
But the point is, what
am I going to do with it?
Because first of
all, it's likely not
going to fit inside my computer.
And even if it does, then
actually processing that data
requires very extensive
computational capabilities
that I wouldn't have.
And the Cloud allow you to have
those very, very cheap price.
Now, in the work
actually with NASA,
Google sponsored that,
so that was not an issue.
But in general, even if
somebody had to pay it,
you only pay for what
you use actually.
Google actually will charge
you by the second literally.
When you have a
machine, if you have it
for 1 minute and 37 seconds to
do a particular computation,
that's exactly what
you'll get charged for.
And so this actually is very
transformative, I think,
in science.
Because now I have
these very large data
sets that are becoming
more and more available,
I have the ability to spawn
with a very cheap price, very
large computation to
analyze that data sets,
and I have this whole
layer of tooling
that, for example, allow me to
create a machine learning model
or to run a very sophisticated
analysis that before actually
would have required maybe me to
get extra time slot on a very
big supercomputer that maybe my
department doesn't have access
to.
So this really allows
everyone to do this.
And I would actually
put it even beyond that.
There are actually a lot
of initiatives right now
around citizenship science--
people that are not
officially scientists
starting to do real science.
And I think, actually
this opens up
a lot of floodgates of
that to happen as well.
SETH SHOSTAK: Well, I was going
to say this sounds like taking
citizen science to the max.
I mean, right, because now
everybody can get to the data.
But beyond that, everybody
has some very competently
written, presumably,
tools to allow
them to look at that data.
So they can look
for correlations.
Or presumably,
they could say, OK,
what I want to find
is some sort of dip
in the brightness of
stars that tells me
that that star has some planets
going around-- whatever it is.
Can you give me another
example of the kinds of things
that you could use this for?
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah, and this
actually is another example
that we worked on this summer
that is also opening up
another stream of thought.
In the second work
we did with NASA,
we were working on astrobiology.
And one of the big problems
in astrobiology is,
assuming there are
planets out there--
and now we know actually that
there are many exoplanets out
there outside of
our solar system--
we want to know actually
whether there is life or not.
The problem of knowing
whether there's life or not
is to also understand
what life is.
I mean, there are many different
kinds of possible lives
that would be conceivable.
And in a sense, actually
we only have one sample--
it's what is on Earth.
So one way around this is
that you could simulate
what life could look like.
And there are
actually various ways.
The thing actually that we
did with FDL this summer
was to basically simulate
metabolic pathways.
So different combinations
of molecules that bond
chemically--
SETH SHOSTAK: Well,
I've got to follow up
on this, because
you can simulate
what extraterrestrial
life might be like.
Now, look, I get called up every
third week by some producer
down in Hollywood
and they're going
to make a film about how aliens
have come to Earth to destroy
downtown Chicago or whatever--
whatever is on their minds.
And they want to know what are
the aliens going to look like.
Now, it sounds like--
[LAUGHTER]
--you've got the tools
to figure that out.
I mean, surely that's not
exactly what you mean.
MASSIMO MASCARO: No.
It is much less
glamorous, if you want.
But actually in
a sense, actually
is also much more interesting.
A lot of what we're
thinking about life today
in terms of humanoid figures and
so on, I mean we can actually
go there but it's likely--
it's actually going
to be very unlikely.
The vast majority of life that
we expect to find on exoplanets
may be just unicellular life.
Or it may not even
cellular-- may just
be some kind of chemical
processes that go on that
signal the fact that there
is actually something
that can be self-reproducing.
SETH SHOSTAK: So in
other words, to begin
with the whole question
of what life is--
I mean, that's a
different question.
And there's actually
no good answer to that.
I many people say,
well, life reproduces,
and metabolic processes
and all that stuff,
uses resources,
maybe moves around.
But that's true of a lot
of physical phenomena
that are not alive, like
fire or something like that.
So in fact, it's not that
you're trying to define life.
You're trying to say what
chemical processes might
lead to something that has
the characteristics of life.
Right?
Is that it?
MASSIMO MASCARO: It is.
And in a sense, it actually
is a restrictive idea of life,
because there may be many, many
larger ways of intending it.
Life could be
completely digital or it
could be actually not even
based on necessary chemistry.
But in the realm of life
that is based on chemistry,
one thing that we know at
least on Earth that life does
is that it changes the chemical
compositions of planets.
In particular, it changes
the chemical composition
of atmospheres of planets.
And the reason
this is interesting
is that we have a shot at
measuring the atmospheres
of some of these exoplanets.
Now, to be clear, today
we cannot do that yet.
At least that's what my
NASA friends tell me.
[LAUGHS] But in
the near future--
I mean, apparently the
James Webb telescope
may be able to do this.
We may be able to detect spectra
of some of these exoplanets.
SETH SHOSTAK: Just to clarify
for people who don't work
in this field, if you
were to look at Earth,
if you were a
cling-on astronomer--
[LAUGHTER]
--I hope they get paid
better than the earthly kind.
But if you were a
cling-on astronomy
and you had a big enough
telescope like James Webb
and you looked at the
Earth with that thing,
you might be able
to find that there's
oxygen in the atmosphere.
20% of the air in this room--
oxygen. But that oxygen
comes from photosynthesis,
so they would say, oh, I
don't know what's there,
Zork, but all that oxygen there
must be lettuce or asparagus
or something that
does photosynthesis.
But that might not be
the only indicator.
Maybe they don't
breathe out oxygen
if they're plants
on another planet.
Is that the idea?
MASSIMO MASCARO:
That's the idea.
And the one thing
actually I want
to say for people who
are not in this field
is that you could actually
say, well, I mean,
couldn't oxygen just
kind of be on that planet
for other reasons?
Well, we know that oxygen binds
a lot to a lot of chemicals.
So it's very likely
that oxygen stays
in an atmosphere
for a long period,
because it would
just oxidize most
of the stuff that is in that
planet and basically bind--
so basically, disappear
from the atmosphere.
SETH SHOSTAK: And it
would turn all the iron
in the soil to rust.
Like Mars, it would become red.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Pretty much.
Mars is a good example.
So the fact that there is
oxygen is because something
is actively producing it.
Now, there are various ways in
which oxygen could be actively
produced by no life systems.
But we know actually of
a lot of metabolic ways
in which this happens.
And actually, oxygen,
to your point,
is not just the only thing.
I mean, in fact, one of the
things actually they told me--
the astrobiologists
that we work this year--
is that actually
in a sense oxygen
is almost like the
smoking gun of life.
Because an oxygen level like
the one that we have on Earth
is almost unlikely to
be actually just kind
of due to geological sources.
But there are many
other chemicals.
For example, just
looking at the ratio
of methane and oxygen or
methane and other components--
sulfur.
There are a lot
of other chemicals
that could actually
manifest signatures of life
being on those planets.
So going back to cloud
and what the problem is,
is that very often there's
digital signatures of what
would be the relative
components of these chemicals
in atmospheres.
We only know them for Earth.
And if you want to know
what the signature will
look like for different
reasonable metabolic pathways,
you would have to simulate that.
And this actually is
what we did with Google.
And one thing, again,
I mean, going back
to the initial
discussion, one thing that
was very useful is the fact
that these simulations are
very expensive computationally.
And in a sense,
actually, it would
take years to run those things
on just even very, very fancy
hardware that a
normal university has.
We were able to spin up
on Google Cloud thousands
of machines in parallel.
And basically the bulk of the
data set that was produced
was produced in a matter
of a couple of weeks.
But just actually spawning
it to a lot of machines
inside our data centers.
SETH SHOSTAK: I got
to say, Massimo,
because I know somebody--
well, Sarah Seager is her name.
She's at MIT and
this is her job.
It's to try and figure out, OK,
if we can measure the whatever
is in the atmosphere or some
planet around some other star,
can we say that
there's life there
or there's not life there.
Are people like that
using the Google Cloud?
Are they already
using these tools
or is this coming down the
pike in the near future?
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah, I think,
actually it's picking up.
So I know that there are a
number of research institutes
and scientific institutions
that are really using Google
Cloud and cloud in general.
I think, one of the things
actually we did at NASA today
this summer and
that in a sense I'm
really hopeful it
creates some movement,
is the fact that we proved
how this can be useful.
Now, one other aspect of
NASA's FDL program to get clear
is that it's a program
that lasts about 10 weeks.
So basically, there
are the scientists
to come and work at actually
FDL here in Mountain View.
And in 10 weeks, they just
have to start and end.
They literally have to finish
their technical reports
in 10 weeks.
And so one other thing
I want to throw in there
is that it doesn't take much.
These guys literally
arrived, they
had absolutely no knowledge
of Google Cloud at all.
I remember actually we
had a meeting at Google
and we were busy explaining
how to spin up machines,
how to train machine learning
models, and there were--
I mean, most of
them actually had
absolutely no prior experience.
And they went
actually in 10 weeks
to publish some very
interesting results.
And now actually they're
talking at conferences.
They're publishing
papers on this.
SETH SHOSTAK: All
right, so what you're
saying is scientists
who are already
doing this or scientists
who want to do this,
they're not going
to have to spend
years learning how to do it.
Right?
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yes.
SETH SHOSTAK: I mean,
they can get trained up
in a couple of
weeks and they can
start doing something useful.
MASSIMO MASCARO: I think so.
And I think, actually,
this is transformative.
Because at the end of the
day, a lot of modern science
is not anymore
just genius people
sitting down with paper and pen
and having a brilliant idea.
It's a lot actually has
to do with data analysis,
with computation,
with simulation.
And I think, actually,
cloud can be transformative.
Now, this actually still
we haven't touched yet
even into the realm of
machine learning and AI.
But I think it's also very,
very interesting and exciting.
But one thing is just actually
the basic of science, I think,
actually cloud can be
very transformative.
And I think it is just a
matter of sometimes of culture
and being used to.
A lot of researchers today
do not know yet these tools.
They haven't experienced them.
And in a sense,
actually, I'm pretty
sure that as soon as they
get to know them better,
they'll find actually that they
can change a lot how they work.
SETH SHOSTAK: Let me take
another specific example here.
In the 1970s, NASA sent
a couple of landers--
the Viking landers-- to
Mars, looking for life
on our little ruddy
buddy up there.
Right?
And the answer they
came back with--
I mean, this cost
a lot of money.
It was like a billion
dollars or something.
I don't remember exactly.
But the answer that came
back was don't know.
We don't think we
found any life,
but of course, we
can't be 100% positive.
Well, obviously,
the space agency
wasn't really happy
with this answer.
And I suppose the
taxpayers to the extent
that they paid attention weren't
very happy either, because you
spent all this money,
you want to know
if there's life on Mars,
and it comes back maybe.
You don't want that.
You want a definitive
answer like 42 or something.
You want a definitive answer.
Now, if they had had the
Google Cloud and these tools
back in the mid
1970s, do you think
they would have had a better
answer in the sense of a more
definitive answer?
MASSIMO MASCARO: I don't know
because that's actually also
whether the answer was
in the data or not.
So what the cloud cannot give
you is answers that are not
in the data.
That said, I think that
for a long time in science
we've actually experienced
this idea that people
work on a particular
problem, they
do an experiment-- let's say
you send an actual NASA probe
or sometimes actually you
do an experiment in a lab.
You collect a lot of data.
You process them in the
best thing which you can.
And actually, you
publish a paper-- maybe?
And that's it.
That's the end of that data.
I think, actually the idea
that this data sets actually
now become public.
And these data sets
are becoming big.
And that people now from all
over the scientific and new
scientific community can go
there and look at those data.
It means that you can now start
squeezing actually much more
information out of
the same data sets.
And actually we can
both validate better
our research result.
And we can also, if we want
to find things that actually
had gone undiscovered--
I mean, case in
point, Kepler data.
Kepler has been
there for 10 years.
And with the help of Kepler,
NASA has been able to declare--
I don't remember
the number-- but I
think, actually it's
north of 2,500 exoplanets,
if I remember correctly.
SETH SHOSTAK: Well, a
little more actually.
MASSIMO MASCARO:
Yeah, a little more.
SETH SHOSTAK: A lot.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Last
year, actually, Google
took that data set.
And this is not
part of this FDL,
this was Google Brain, our
AI Research Department.
Took the data set
and it basically
applied machine learning to it.
And it did discover a
number of exoplanets
that had gone undiscovered.
In fact, they discovered
an entire exoplanet system
that looks quite like the
Earth, that have completely
gone undiscovered.
Now, I mean, on one
side is the ability
to have access to the data.
So that's very important.
And I think, actually NASA's
doing an excellent job
in making all those
data sets public.
And I think a lot of
other institutions
and even university labs
should just follow suit.
And some are, but even more.
Every data set in my
opinion in science,
especially if it's publicly
funded, should be public.
But then that's not
sufficient either.
Because now I have
this gigantic data set,
and there is no way
if I don't have access
to the NASA supercomputer,
I can actually
extract information from it.
So the idea that now actually as
somebody-- the guys at Google,
actually--
it was done actually
with an astronomer
at the University of Texas,
if I remember correctly.
But the other guy
actually here at Google
was just an AI engineer.
And they basically sat
down together and said,
OK, let's reanalyze this.
And they found exoplanet
that got missing.
So I think, actually, this
is a great opportunity for us
to extract more information
out of the data sets that
very often costly we collect.
And actually, to also understand
better what's sometimes
actually wrong,
because maybe sometimes
actually the problem is that
an analysis that has been
done actually may be wrong.
And the idea that other
people can look at the data
actually makes it
much more verifiable.
That is actually one of
the principle of science.
SETH SHOSTAK: There are
coming down the pike
some really big telescopes.
And we're talking about
astronomy here a lot.
But they're--
MASSIMO MASCARO: That's nice.
SETH SHOSTAK:
Well, that's right.
There's going to
be telescopes that
can look at the entire
sky, every four days,
that sort of thing.
See things that we've
never seen before.
I mean, there could be
flashing lights in the sky,
we would never see them because
the telescopes are never
looking in the right
place at the right time.
So we're going to have
instruments that can do that.
We're also building these
huge telescopes here
with mirrors that are
20, 30 meters across.
And obviously, they're going
to be able to do things that
our current telescopes can't.
So the instrumentation is
certainly getting a lot better.
But it produces enormous
tons, mountains of data
that nobody can go
through anymore.
This is not like
in the old days--
when I was a kid just
before the Crimean War.
When I was a kid you
would go to the telescope,
you'd put a photographic
plate at the back end of it,
you'd make a
photograph, and then
that plate would go
in your desk drawer.
Nobody else could get to it.
Nobody else could look at it.
And maybe you didn't
ever look at it.
So obviously, that's
going to change.
It sounds like the
researchers are going
to become data scientists.
MASSIMO MASCARO: I think,
actually more and more.
I mean, I think, actually
in part they already are.
If you think about how most
of the research I have done
personally was really at the
border between data science,
data analysis.
And actually, in
my case, actually I
was studying computation
neuroscience.
I was trying to understand
how the brain works.
But it was a lot of
heavy data analysis.
But the other aspect is that
these data sets, to your point,
are becoming more
and more gigantic.
And they actually are
more and more complex too.
I mean, of these
telescopes require
you to do all sorts of
processing into this data.
And this processing
may sometimes
actually change the data.
So sometimes you have
to do different kinds
of pre-processing.
This actually was the case
of Kepler, for example.
And so the idea that you have
now this vast computation
infrastructure, this vast
analytic infrastructure,
and then actually we can talk
a little bit about machine
learning as well,
because I think,
actually, that's also going
to play a huge role there.
I think, actually, that's
going to be transformative.
Now, one last thing
actually on this point
is the fact that I
think more and more
we're also starting to see data
collection happening outside
of the realm of
gigantic instruments
that, let's say, NASA
actually deploys.
There is an interesting
project that I
got to know about
where they put actually
this kind of small telescope.
These are almost amateurish
telescopes, basically
all around the globe to
track these exoplanets.
And the idea is
that TESS actually
will only look at a certain
patch of the sky for 28
days at a time.
And so maybe actually
another telescope
will pick up from there
and start doing this.
And again, this
actually organizes
data sets and becomes
really fundamental now
to be able to go
across data sets.
Not just being able to apply
the big guns of supercomputers
or the cloud into
a particular data
sets, but being able to
spawn between data sets that
very often have very
different shapes, forms,
and they need actually
very different kind
of pre-processing
and ability to part.
So that actually also is
going across data sets.
It's going to be
very transformative.
SETH SHOSTAK: Well,
I have to say,
I mean, in my line
of work, you're
looking for a radio signal or
a light signal coming from ET.
And we get lots of signals.
It's not like in
the movies where
you're sitting
around looking bored
and suddenly you see a spike on
the screen and everybody jumps
up and starts screaming
and calling up
the press and all that.
What actually happens is every
10 seconds you get a signal.
But those signals can
be very messy looking.
And AI might be just the ticket
to sort through those millions
and millions of signals you're
getting every day and decide,
OK, this is interference from
a satellite, this is maybe ET,
this is not ET,
that kind of thing.
I mean, personally, this sounds
like a very attractive thing.
We've been talking a lot about
astronomy and space research.
Can you give me another example?
I'm just thinking there must
be huge data sets out there,
which talk about
various diseases--
people get a certain
kind of cancer.
And this is maybe their diets
or their lifestyle or something
else and nobody has
the ability to see
if there's a slight
correlation with maybe eating
broccoli and getting
cancer of the elbows
or something like that.
I mean--
MASSIMO MASCARO:
Those actually are
big topics you may have heard.
Google actually is
very vested into health
and we're working a lot in it.
Actually very recently we
created a whole division
called Google Health that
will work on those problems.
Some of the early
results in that area
are mind-boggling in that
it's not only about the fact
that you can now actually infer
across very, very large data
sets and understand
this is better.
It's the fact that
very often you
then actually get
also diagnosis that
are much more democratized.
So to give you an
example, one of the work
that Google is doing is
to basically understand
from images of the eye,
of your retina, whether--
basically, they look at
your blood patterns there.
And then actually they
can infer whether you
have certain kinds of diabetes.
Now, this is transformative,
because if you
can do this for real--
and this is actually
still very experimental and it
still has to be a lot verified.
But if you can start doing this
with a camera on a smartphone,
that means that
somebody that is let's
say in a poor
region of the world
and hasn't access to super good
health systems and doctors,
would just going to be able
to point his phone at his eye
and know something very, very
important about his health.
It also, of course, actually
even in rich countries
where we have access
to health care,
it means actually much
easier prevention.
I think that that's going
to change a lot of things.
Now, going back to the
problem, again, you
can do this if you can
actually build systems
that are able to very often
understand the minute, very
subtle kind of patterns
inside images, data
set, temporal streams, whatnot.
So that's actually
where very often you
need to do very extensive
machine learning
on very large data sets,
because in order for you
to detect those
patterns you have
to be able to identify those
patterns into very large data
sets.
And that's again--
SETH SHOSTAK: So this brings to
mind a couple of possibilities.
One is in the diagnosis realm--
I'm fortunate I live
here in California.
And if I don't feel well,
I can go to my physician.
And he's seen me for years and
since I walk into his office
he already has made
some analysis of me,
because he knows what I should
look like-- that kind of thing.
But I think it's
already the case--
I mean, there have been
some demos of this, right?
That if you let the AI do the
analysis or the diagnosis,
that it might be a
little more accurate
than the human physician
because it doesn't forget all
those rare conditions that the
physician has because they've
never seen them.
So there is that.
And then there's the
question of, indeed,
if you're in a part of the world
where you don't have access
to that kind of health care,
that maybe your phone, which
allows you to maybe do
some of these measurements,
send that to the AI, and
then it diagnoses you,
and you get a better
level of health care.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Again, I mean,
this is still very early times
and this is actually still very
much in the domain of research
and science.
But I think,
actually, this is one
of the transformations that's
going to happen in health care.
I do agree with you that very
often actually today health
care--
I mean, while we have
wonderful doctors
and the health care
science actually
has improved as we probably
could never have dreamed,
even like 20, 30 years ago--
we know that there
are actually a lot
of differences between doctors.
I mean, and the fact that
the doctor is a human person,
a human being, is a factor.
I mean, your doctor may have
himself a health issue the day
before he's visiting you.
And maybe he's not actually
completely at his best.
Or he just actually
may have like a worry,
because I don't know--
had an argument with his
son actually the night
before visiting you.
And again, that's one
issue with humans, right?
SETH SHOSTAK: Will they
have a good bedside manner?
I mean, that's a question you
probably get all the time.
I like my doctor because
he jokes around with me.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yes.
But that's actually
what I'm saying
is that machine learning is
completely struck from this.
If you have a machine
learning that works,
it will work in a
very consistent way.
So that's primary, but
of course, actually we
don't have yet holistically
machine learning
systems that can even get
close to match current doctors.
But that actually is
where a lot of research
is going right now, because
it is going to transform
completely the field.
Now, going back to science,
I mean, the path ahead
of the doctor giving you a
full diagnosis being driven
by an AI, I think it is
actually doing a lot of research
into applying AI to medicine.
And it just goes
into the discussion
we're having about science.
Because those AIs
always come from you
having churned
through a lot of data
and having matched whatever the
AIs, in this case predicting
or diagnosing, with
what you know is true.
And actually this requires a lot
of work in actual basic science
to start with.
SETH SHOSTAK: We're getting
some questions from the viewers.
And here's one.
Could you explain the
usage of the Google Cloud
tools in the context of the
NASA Frontier Development Lab
for its challenges, which are
in the fields of exo and astro?
So you might want to explain
what exo and astro are.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah, so those
were the two things actually
we touched on.
So exo is our exoplanet
search work with FDL
where we were basically trying
to train machine learning
algorithms that would detect
exoplanet passage into the data
from Kepler and then TESS.
And astro [INAUDIBLE]
the astrobiology work.
It really was two
streams of work.
One stream was about simulating
these metabolic pathways
to understand what,
again, life could
look like on these exoplanets.
And then the second
part was simulating
how those metabolic pathways
would affect the spectrum
that you would-- spectrum is
basically the different colors
that you basically see, the
different frequencies of light
that you see actually as light
passes through the atmosphere.
And when you actually
have that phenomenon,
you can actually detect
what kind of chemicals
are inside the atmosphere.
Of course, there is a lot that
goes on inside this process
and so what is in the atmosphere
doesn't correlate one to one,
and what the spectrum look like.
And so the second
part was really
characterizing this
kind of light signature
as basically a
spectrum of planets.
So going to the
question, the tools
actually that we use actually
were very wide-spanning.
So one side, as I said, we
had actually all the data
coming into Google Cloud.
We actually spun a
lot of computation.
So a lot of the simulations have
been run inside Google Cloud.
We took some very, very
sophisticated codes
that actually NASA
had developed for,
for example,
simulating atmospheres.
And we basically adapted
them to run on Google Cloud.
And then we run them as
very, very large scales.
Then the second part is that
those machine learning modules
actually have to be built. So
on the machine learning side,
a lot of the
researchers actually
use extensively something
that is becoming very, very
popular in data science
and in general ML research
is the ability to
of write notebooks.
Now, for those of you
who are not technical,
a notebook is
basically a document
where you can basically
put code and execute in it.
And you can actually
have graphics being
done inside that document.
So we had actually a system
that would allow our researchers
to spawn their notebooks
inside our infrastructure
and then run machine
learning through that.
Also, Google actually
provides a number of tools
to do what is called
serverless training.
That is, you can basically
submit a piece of code
to Google Cloud
and basically say
this is my algorithms
that I need to train
and that's actually
where the data is.
And this service that's called
Machine Learning Engine, ML
Engine, from France, will
basically take this code
and ultimately
train it by actually
spawning the necessary
machines on the back-end.
So this was very useful,
because again, you
don't have to care about
how many machine I have here
or there, and actually
spawning up the machines
with the right environments.
So these actually were
the main basic tools.
Now of course, as part of this,
those researchers-- and this
is actually one thing I care
a lot in terms of people
understanding-- they
loaded into Google Cloud
a lot of open-source code
and scientific libraries
that they found
useful for their work.
And this actually
is the cool thing.
I mean, you don't have
to think about, OK, I
have to do this work
on Google Cloud,
so I'm going to let go all the
tools that I'm familiar with
and I'll get to learn
all these other tools.
And maybe Google Cloud is
not made for astrophysics
or chemical research.
SETH SHOSTAK: It doesn't
involve a complete reset
of your career, is that
what you're saying?
MASSIMO MASCARO:
It does not at all.
SETH SHOSTAK: Then let me ask
you because obviously people
want to know, OK,
this sounds great,
can you point to some
concrete results?
I mean, has the Google
Cloud published a paper?
Is the Nobel Prize
committee calling up?
I mean, maybe the cloud is
going to get to go to Sweden.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah,
so first of all, I mean,
one thing actually I want
to make sure it's clear
is that these were actually
researchers working
for this program, and they're
actual researchers that work
very often in universities.
They're usually postgraduate
students or postdocs
or some actually assistant
professor that was mentoring.
So as Google Cloud, we're
not going to publish a paper.
Those researchers
will be and there
are few actually that
are coming down the line.
In terms of concrete
results, I'll
mention a couple of things.
The first one is that on the
exoplanet search research
the team actually was
able to train a model
to recognize those planets
inside the Kepler data sets.
And then actually we simulated
that data set for tests.
So again, as I said
at the beginning,
we don't have yet the TESS data,
so we couldn't run it there.
But we simulated a
data set from TESS.
NASA has a very, very
sophisticated simulation
of what TESS data
would look like.
And they were able to train a
model on that, that on one side
is more accurate at least in
percentages than what we know
are the accuracies from the
previous models that have been
attempted, including
the one from Google AI
that I was mentioning before,
and including actually
the human performance that
is currently estimated.
That is, astronomer
looking at the data.
So the model was more accurate.
And I think, actually that
was, of course, a great result.
But to me actually
even more exciting,
the model ended up being a
couple of orders of magnitude
smaller than the previous
attempts at models.
That is, it's a
very small model.
It's very compact.
And what this allows
is now actually
to consider running this
inline with data collection.
Because before a lot of
those models actually
were pretty heavy and they
required a lot of computation.
So they couldn't have been
run as the data arrived.
Being able to run a
model as data arrives
opens up a number
of possibilities.
For example, what
I mentioned before.
If there is actually
a particular detection
on TESS data as basically the
data set is getting extreme,
it means actually
you can now alert
other telescopes or
other researchers
about that potential detection.
And it means actually
collecting other data
from other sources that
could confirm or deny
that particular planet or maybe
extract other characteristics.
One of the thing that I
mentioned in the beginning
is that TESS actually
will only look
at a patch of the
sky for 28 days.
One limitation of this-- and
this actually is not completely
true, because there is a
patch where they look actually
for an entire year--
but in those
patches you only get
to see planets that have
very, very short orbits,
because the planet
has to go around.
SETH SHOSTAK: Inner planets.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Exactly.
And sometimes actually
you could see a transit,
but then you don't get
to see the second transit
as it comes around because
it's taking too long.
But this actually could be
great candidates, for example,
for NASA to now say, hey, we
have this potential candidates
of planets.
We don't know A, whether
they're real planets or not; B,
how long actually it will
take to retransit again.
And maybe we can
have, again, this
is in science maybe
or other telescopes
or other researchers,
they count on that
and augment the TESS data sets.
SETH SHOSTAK: Massi,
I mean, clearly this
is kind of revolutionary.
Maybe I should excise
the words kind of--
it's revolutionary.
I mean, it seems that we're
at the beginning where we've
opened the door to a
whole new way of analyzing
data and learning
things about the cosmos,
but about nature in general.
Have we reached a tipping point?
This is philosophical,
but you've
figured that 500
years from now people
will look back at the
beginning of the 21st century
and say, the most important
thing that happened
then was not reality television
or anything like that.
[LAUGHTER]
It was the beginning of AI
applied to real world problems.
MASSIMO MASCARO: I
think, actually, we're
at the tipping point where
this actually may happen.
I could actually
tell you that, again,
and I'm working in AI in a
much broader, if you want,
spectrum of things
than science itself.
AI is changing a lot
of the way in which we
think about problems.
In science, it's
one of the problem
that we as humans think of.
It's probably one of
the most important one,
because it's about understanding
our universe and ourselves.
But AI is really kind
of at a tipping point
where, if you want,
it's now starting
to lead to results where
we can now solve problems
in a very, very different way.
Now, for scientists,
in particular,
I think going back--
I don't know in 500
years-- but going back we
could really see that starting
from the '90s and then
in the last two decades,
more and more, if you want,
computers have been
applied to science.
I mean, the initial
computers were almost
developed for science.
But now actually it's
becoming so prominent
that the idea of doing
science without computers
is completely
preposterous today.
And I think, actually,
in a few decades,
it may be that the idea of
doing science without AI
would be as preposterous as
today is the idea of doing
science without computers.
SETH SHOSTAK: But what
about doing science
without the scientists?
I mean, how far can this go?
MASSIMO MASCARO:
So this actually
is an interesting point.
I'll tell actually
an anecdote on this.
So during one of
the final reviews--
French technical reviews that
we had with Frontier Development
Lab with FDL, who
were actually a number
of labs-- of course, NASA
researchers and [INAUDIBLE],,
I mean the teams actually
were showing some
of those results made with AI.
And there were actually a lot of
questions about, well, I mean,
like if this AI is
predicting-- so for example,
there was one study about
predicting solar activity
and where they would actually
be able to predict much
better than the physical
models that the scientists had
basically created for that.
And one question is
that, well, I mean,
this thing is predicting
better than we are doing,
but it's not really
explaining what is going on.
At the end of the day, I
mean, in science, we want
to understand the mechanism.
We want to understand
the physics behind it.
So I think, actually that--
I mean, at least in
the spectrum of what
we know today of
what the AI is doing,
there is a lot of
space for scientists.
Because eventually, these tools
will simulate a lot of data,
will may actually be
able to detect patterns,
may be able to refine
data sets in ways
that we're not able to do
as scientists, as humans.
But at the end of the
day, we also want to--
I mean, science is really
about understanding the why--
is that really
kind of going back
to that kind of physical law
or like understanding actually
the mechanism.
SETH SHOSTAK: Well, you're
talking about insight here.
I mean, Newton didn't
have AI working for him.
He had his brain
and it turned out
that was good enough
to understand many--
but he didn't have
huge data sets.
He had very limited data sets.
Now, take a field such as,
well, you know a lot about.
That's neuroscience.
Right?
They said the most complex
thing in the universe
is the human brain.
This may be an insult
to the Klingons, but--
[LAUGHTER]
--who's to say.
And I suppose that at the
very small level where
you have individual neurons and
so forth, and synapses and all
that stuff, that you might
understand the chemistry,
you might understand the physics
of what's going on there.
But that doesn't mean that you
understand how thinking works,
because that's very complex.
This sounds like a
perfect application
of this new technology,
but will it provide indeed
the understanding of what
happens or does it just
give you a model and you
just input a lot of data
and now you can tell
what the next thought is.
MASSIMO MASCARO:
Yeah, I mean, this
goes to what I
was saying before.
That is, right now
actually you could--
I mean, there are applications
of AI, believe me,
in neuroscience as well,
where they would actually
start predicting
what neurons does
or what extra group
of neurons does.
However, it doesn't explain
necessarily how that works.
So I think, again, it goes a
little bit into philosophy.
It's a very important
thing today actually
we don't get to do with AI.
However, in the
context of brain,
I think it is even more
if you want involved.
Because in the
sense of what we're
trying to do with AI
in a certain sense
is to create artificial
intelligence.
That's what the
word comes about.
And one of the big
questions about the brain
is, what is intelligence
and how does it work?
If you can actually
create alternate versions
of intelligence, they
may not have anything
to do with how the brain works.
It still gives you
a lot of insights
of what intelligence could be
or how intelligence could work,
or what are the limitations of
intelligence in certain areas
or others.
So I think, actually,
for neuroscience,
I would say there
is the data part,
there is the prediction
part, that is
the same as with all sciences.
But then the specific
problem that you
solve when you've studied
neuroscience, or at least one
of the specific
problems, it's very, very
close to what the essence of
artificial intelligence is.
SETH SHOSTAK: Wait, is
that like 100 years ago--
a little more now--
when they were trying to
build flying machines,
they tried at first
to imitate birds.
We'll have wings that
flap and so forth.
And that turned out not
to be the right approach.
They developed something where
the wings don't move at all
and you just have a big
propeller in the front.
I mean, that's not the way.
Very few of the birds in my
backyard have propellers.
And yet they could
make machines,
they could fly pretty darn well.
But in the end, that
actually gave them insights
into how birds fly.
So are you talking
about something
like that, where you
build a machine that
can do some thinking
process, but it
doesn't work at all
like the human brain
but that might be helpful?
MASSIMO MASCARO: So if you
want like a jet engine,
it's not very similar
to a bird even if it has
some kind of characteristics.
And a helicopter is complete
different than a bird.
However, the principle
that make things fly apply.
And in a sense,
actually if you want,
if you go to the very kind
of bedrock of what flying is,
of how we generate
lift, you can actually
learn a lot from birds.
But you can learn also a
lot from helicopters and jet
engines.
So the idea here
is that our brain
is a way of doing
intelligence, and if you
build another way of
doing intelligence maybe
by completely different means,
that may actually still give
you insights about the bedrock
of what intelligence is
and how intelligence works.
Now that said, I would
actually just for the public
say that the most successful
way of doing AI today
is deep learning.
And it's based on this
idea of neural networks.
That a lot of people
that as me actually
have studied computation
neuroscience will say,
oh, neural networks are very
different from the brain.
And it's true.
They are very, very
different from the brain.
However, they have
a lot of analogies.
And those analogies actually
may give us a hint about, again,
that bedrock, about what
intelligence is and how
actually you can build
systems that learn,
because at the end
of the day, I mean,
intelligence is a
very fuzzy word.
But learning is something that
we are much more familiar with.
SETH SHOSTAK: Well, I mean,
Google did this experiment in,
what, 2012?
I don't quite remember.
But they took 16,000 processors,
whatever it was, and they
let it loose on the internet
and said, go find something,
and it found cats, with very
high accuracy by the way.
I mean it found
cats probably better
than any cat could find cat.
I don't know.
And you can say, well,
that's not very useful.
But of course, the fact
that it could see things
on the internet.
I mean, so that's--
I guess that's machine learning.
But I think a lot of people
regard all these capabilities--
the fact that if you're
a Go player or a poker
player or a chess
player, there's
a machine that can beat you.
They regard them as a threat.
And should we be
looking at it that way?
AI, is that going
to take my job?
Is it going to
destroy my lifestyle?
What's your view?
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah, so
my personal view on this
is that, I think, actually
this is one of the greatest
opportunity of humanity.
So I see it actually as
with a very optimistic take.
I wouldn't work
on it, if I wasn't
very optimistic about it.
That said, I think, actually AI
does have dangers and does have
questions that we have to solve
both in applicative ways--
so what are the constraints
where you want to apply AI--
and also from a
society perspective.
One thing we did at Google
is that we very recently
this summer came out for--
we're the first company
to really do that--
come up with AI principles.
So we have actually
a code of conduct
in terms of where we
think AI could be applied
and where it shouldn't,
and how it should
be applied when it's there.
Now, I personally don't think
that this kind of debate
can only be in the realm of
a corporation like Google.
Google, of course, has a lot
of investment and trust in AI,
but it's not the
only player here.
And I think, actually
we should have
more of a societal
discussion about this.
SETH SHOSTAK: Is that
realistic, though?
I mean, 99% of the
world agrees, yes,
we have to have these
boundaries-- whatever--
but the 1% that doesn't believe
in that or sees some advantage
to themselves--
it sounds like there
might be some--
MASSIMO MASCARO: As a
prominent researcher
Nick Bostrom pointed out, AI
is intrinsically adversarial.
Because to your point,
it just takes 1%
to do the things that
they shouldn't do.
In a sense, this is not very
dissimilar to other kind
of dangerous things that
we do, from nanotechnology
to biotechnology and
things like those.
But that's actually is
why it's important to have
that societal discussion.
Because I don't think,
actually any corporation,
any institution
itself, on his own
actually can really put
the right boundaries.
I think it's really--
it's becoming more and
more a humanity discussion.
And it's interesting because we
are in a point of our history,
of our world, where it
seems actually we're
getting more fractured
instead of getting more united
as a global humanity.
And I see actual danger in that.
On the other side, this could be
things actually that unite us.
Because to your point,
I think the majority
of the people on
Earth would agree
on a number of those things.
SETH SHOSTAK: Well,
finally, then Massi, I mean,
it sounds like we're at a
stage in the development
of technology here--
kind of analogous to the
invention of the microscope,
the telescope.
These were tools that
allowed us to suddenly make
big discoveries.
It sounds like you're saying
that the 21st century--
the first half of
the 21st century--
we might see not only the
detection of lots of planets,
but life on those planets,
maybe even intelligent life
on those planets.
And in medicine,
we might be curing
all sorts of diseases
that have stymied us
for hundreds of years.
And you wouldn't want
to rule out the tools.
I mean, you want to
embrace those tools.
What's your advice
to young people
who are getting interested
in science and technology?
MASSIMO MASCARO:
So again, I think,
actually it's an amazing time.
I've always been very passionate
about science and technology.
And when I was young,
it used to be that--
I mean, unless you
were really lucky to go
to a good university
and you have access
to libraries and
journals, you can't really
learn a lot of things.
Nowadays, I mean, young
people can go on YouTube
and watch lessons of the
best professors in the best
universities for free.
And this actually
is great content.
You guys can play with
things, as I said.
It doesn't take a lot of money.
And by the way, I mean, there
are also educational programs.
If you guys are
interested, you can ping us
at Google Cloud, where we can
actually give you credits.
But what I'm saying
is that it doesn't
take much to get and even
do serious science if you
are interested in it.
And I think, this actually
democratizes science
enormously.
And I'm really hoping that
for the young people that
are listening to us,
that they'll get actually
the passion for science
in the right way.
And now they have all
the tools literally
inside their laptop to
go and do seriously it.
And I think, actually
this is the point.
This actually enlarges
the targeted population
for scientists by a number
of order of magnitude
from what it used to be.
SETH SHOSTAK: It sounds
like we're opening doors--
big doors--
I think people will have the
motivation to walk through.
Massimo Mascaro, thanks so
very much for speaking with us.
I'm Seth Shostak.
Thank you for tuning in.
And we'll see you in another
Google Facebook Live.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Thank you.